I am totally alone right now with only
my thoughts I love it I'm loving
it I can literally say anything I
want no one is going to hear me wish I
could have gone with Ryan on that cool
Retreat J's plastic
boobs I have
amids doesn't even matter Michael is a
man of great depth and
passion I don't know what he's searching
for out
here I hope he finds
it
lunch well it is a little
chillier than I had thought so I have
fashioned my hat back into my
pants several hours in it's time for me
to find some nourishment now these Woods
are full of creatures that can sustain
human life things like uh squirrels uh
nice juicy rabbit would be
delicious about two more
minutes I have made this spear with
which I will impale my
dinner and it couldn't come a moment too
soon because I have been without food
for a good
three hours or
so starting to feel it a little
bit
oh it's greed's birthday
today happy birthday to
you happy birthday to
you happy birthday dear
Creed happy bir
birthday to
you happy birthday
buddy